welcome to the heavy spoilers show i'm
your host paul
aka the worst thing to pop up on the
internet since pop-ups
and this video we're breaking down all
the commercials so far in one division
these strange intermissions have been
dotted throughout the season
and though they just seem like some fun
little gags on the surface
there's actually a lot going on with
them we start with our first one for the
toastmate
all the way back in episode 1 and are
introduced to a male and female
character
who appeared throughout most of the
adverts though we don't know who these
people are
it has been theorized that they are
actually wanda and pietro's parents
that were killed when they were younger
after being admitted from the yo magic
commercial
it was the arise that they didn't appear
because the pair were dead by this
decade
but we'll discuss that later in the
video now our first one shows the
toastmate 2000
being advertised by the man and woman
played by it maher enriquez
and victoria blade as in blade the
vampire hunter
it's all connected we're introduced to a
broken piece of crap
and it mahar says is your husband tired
of you burning his toast
this of course plays on the gender roles
of the time in which men were primarily
seen as the bread winners
whereas women were seen as the bread
burners
hey you have a lot now he kind of mocks
the audience for being stupid enough to
use an older toaster
before taking us to the toastmate 2000
made by stock industries
this is laced with a lot of hidden
meanings and there are a couple of
details in this that you need to pay
attention to
so get off your bloody phone now the
first one is that we're watching
something that is broken
then being replaced by a model that has
all of the same functions
but seems better this could be in
relation to vision
who was of course killed in infinity war
before being brought back for the series
in tom king's division he was actually
given the nickname toaster
and the front of the machine itself
looks like a bit of a smiley face
with the light in the middle of that
potentially representing the mind stone
the stark logo industry likely
represents the missile that landed in
front of her
back when she was younger this didn't
detonate but staring at that logo made
her and her brother hey tony
because it wouldn't be an mcu movie if
every single villain wasn't somehow
created by him
it's all connected now the sound of the
toaster being activated
also sounds like when the ark reactor
powers up perhaps tying back to this
you also get the slogan forget the past
this is your future
which of course aligns not only with the
idea of the series
but the avengers themselves in one
division
wonder of course took vision and started
a seemingly new and perfect life
and due to the amnesia that the pair
suffer from they have very much
forgotten what led to them being in west
view
wonder also forgot her hatred of the
avengers and ended up joining them
perhaps linking back to that line though
it could be a reach
now the beeping red light on the toaster
starts to speed up
and this could hint at time in the hex
moving faster than it is on the outside
world
billy and tommy of course grew up very
fast and the decade switches
make me wish i had time in a bottle
because they went by
in a flash oh wait that doesn't work
anyway another interesting element that
centers around time
is that we actually see two clocks in
the side one over the man's shoulder
and then over the woman's shoulder the
first one displays the time as being six
whereas the ladder displays it as noon
or midnight
potentially hinting to us at how time
inside the hex can be day
whereas on the outside it can be night
there's also a little lobster in the
back which could be a reference to the
one that appears as wonders door knocker
at the end of the episode
it's all connected how the commercials
themselves
also tie to the infinity stones in some
way and
as we know from the films wander's power
draws from one
it is possible that these commercials
are hinting to us that she has to
recreate them in order to stabilize the
universe
as we know from avengers endgame that
they have a huge impact on things
if this is the case then this one
represents the mind stone
and bear this in mind when we get to the
next ad
that's not even a good one is it anyway
cut to the struck a watch being shown in
episode two
and this centering around the timepiece
makes me think that it's connected to
the time stone
strucker himself was actually paramount
in turning wonder and pietro into super
powered beings
and the villain featured in the winter
soldier post credits scene before he
popped up
at the start of age of ultron connected
to hydra the villain was paramount and
twisting their bodies so that he could
use them as weapons
and he's had a huge impact on wonder's
life now an interesting thing about the
advert
is that the time change is in it
initially when we first see the watch
it appears to be about ten past nine yet
seconds later
it's 2 42. in the background of the ad
we can also hear the ticking of the
watch getting faster and faster
again time back to this idea of time
accelerating
jump over to the one in episode three
for hydra soak and we see the woman back
except this time she has two children
this is likely playing on the idea that
wonder herself gets two kids in the
episode
called billy and tommy which just so
happens to be the name of both my
grandfathers
it's all connected wait is that is that
right okay
getting a bit weird now that kevin
careful with that anyway
a kid kicks a football at the table
which then sends her food flying
the dog pees in the kitchen she
overcooked some food
and the lender goes everywhere we hear a
voice say
do you need a break to which she replies
you read my mind
she closes her eyes and finds herself
transported to a luxurious bath
where she's being fanned by the man the
voiceover then says
come with me escape to a world all your
own where your problems flow away
now the do you need a bright comment
could be referring to wonder
grieving over the death of vision at the
end of end game
unlike tony because he wasn't viewed as
being a real person
the character was not given a funeral
and sword experimenting on his body has
shown that there is very little respect
for him or wonders wishes
the mind reading comment could be
referring to agnes physically going
through wanda's thoughts
and then giving her the ability to have
a break in west view
this dream reality of the woman soaking
in the bath whilst being adorned is also
very similar to the aesthetic of the
city
in which he has found the goddess within
and is controlling all of reality
hydra of course ties back to wanda's
history as
she gained her powers through their
experiments and the blue box itself
does look like the tesseract hydra soap
was actually referenced in agents of
shield when phil coulson said that it
had mind-altering powers
and though we don't know whether they're
behind this whole thing or not it would
make some sense
episode 4 doesn't have any commercials
so it's not
all connected but it is connected
because it's connected to the show
so it's all connected also if you're
enjoying the video then please click the
thumbs up
and subscribe to the channel otherwise
i'll kill you and i'll kill your whole
family now jump to episode 5
and we see an ad for lagos which i
actually found out from one of my
followers
obie who lives in the city that it's
pronounced lagos
obi you got yourself a follow and kevin
feige you got yourself an
unfollow yes some of a [ __ ] now this is
an amazing paper towel that's much
better than the leading
brand and it could be hinting at how
wonder vastly overpowers the sword
members outside the hex
in a moment that actually precedes this
ad now lago
sorry lagos is the city that featured at
the beginning of civil war
and it's of course where wonder ended up
killing lots of people
which eventually forced the un to strike
up the sokovia records
the tagline of the paper is for when you
make a mess you didn't mean to
and this of course ties into how she was
trying to stop the detonation crossbones
set off but it still led to the deaths
of several people
now an interesting facet of this
commercial is that the man actually does
some cleaning too
and in the briar ones all of the busy
work had been handled by the woman
this is commenting on how gender norms
were starting to all throughout the time
and that men started chipping in too it
also ties in with the episode itself
as vision starts to alter how he comes
across
and whereas earlier in the season he
very much fit in with the illusion
he starts to question what's really
going on as for the infinity stone that
this ties in with
i think due to the red liquid that we
see being cleaned up that it is related
to the reality stone
and that too can alter things similar to
how the paper
alters or alters the mess i guess
anyway cut to the yo magic ad and this
video is about
yo mama ryan airy
i got you sucker now unlike the ads that
came before
this actually doesn't feature the man
and woman and instead it's a claymation
commercial that plays on the style at
the time
seen in things like celebrity death
match yo magic is a nod to yo plate
a yogurt brand and it features a boy
stranded on a desert island who's
visited by a cool surfing shark
this shark could be seen as being a play
on quicksilver
as they both shot about of nowhere and
seem to be too cool for school
both the shark and pietro use a term
little dude throughout the episode
and they seem very much to want to keep
the characters where they are
the shark could easily surf out there
with the kid and pietro at several
points tells wanda that everything's
awesome in west view
especially their hair the boy tries to
open the packet but he's unable to
and he withers away and dies like all
the hopa had for 2021 being a good yeah
seven days into it this is arguably the
most laid out of all of the ads that
we've seen
the time passing quickly on the island
is likely a nod to how it moves in the
hex
compared to the rest of the world the
child could represent the children of
west view
who up until this point were absent from
the area it has been thought that they
were fast asleep in their beds
and if this is the case they were likely
starving until wonder found them
something to do
while you're stealing all the
trick-or-treat candy quicksilver these
lads
they've not eaten for weeks now now it
could also be referencing how vision
attempts to escape the hex later in the
episode
upon leaving he's slowly dismantled to
the point that he's just about to die
before wonder expands it all of the
commercials so far
are pulling from a trauma in wonder's
life and this might reference the death
of vision
as he two turned grey upon being killed
your magic's tagline is the snack for
survivors
and this may also reference how wanda
was a child that was experimented on
and she survived whereas the rest of the
youngsters that were given the magic
didn't now lassie could be a nod to how
the town is actually operating
as wanda was given a boost in her magic
and this made her remain in a
centralized location
similar to the island however something
else was a foot here
or rather a fin little shark joke there
and west view could actually be draining
her life force
monica said that in the heck she could
sense the endless emptiness that wonder
felt
and thus the child dying of an empty
stomach
could be referencing the emptiness i
can't even finish that sentence where i
reach
now this child is constantly trying to
pull out the yoghurt but it's not really
real
and this might line up with how wonder
keeps trying to force vision to be a
certain way
even though he will inevitably not give
in to her the ad itself also seems to be
referencing the soul stone
due to its use of death and the sun
which appears to be similar to stone
itself
the skull that we see and the red
t-shirt could be playing on the red
skull
due to the features and it does seem to
line up with that more than the other
remaining stones
now the latest commercial from episode 7
features the woman sitting on a bench by
herself
and we also see what i think are the two
children from the commercials running
past her
if these have represented wicked and
speed in the past then it makes sense
that they're fleeing
leaving her by herself as in the entry
agnes takes them to her house
to harvest their souls both victoria
blade and ipmahara turn
which i think negates the idea that they
are wander's parents
though it could be a out of the snap and
how some people vanished for some time
before coming back like my wife's herpes
what now the woman on the bench to me
very much represents wonder and if all
of the commercials are in reference to a
trauma from her past
then this is likely the group that she
felt in the aftermath of endgame
most of the people who died in infinity
war were brought back
even gamora and thus she did get
shortchanged in some ways
at one point in the ad the character
also appears in bed by herself
which mirrors the opening of the episode
namely wonder being alone in bed too
the advertisement centers around an
antidepressant known as nexus
that allows you to be anchored to your
reality or a reality of your choice
wonder of course created westview and
this is commenting on how the journey
she had
could have been controlled by an outside
force as it was
agatha all along now the side effects of
the pill are that they leave you feeling
your feelings
confronting your truth and seizing your
destiny
perhaps sending out wonder becoming
scarlet witch
nexus actually has a lot of meanings
throughout the marvel universe
and a nexus point is the doorway between
dimensions which many have theorized the
hex actually
is this would explain how agatha was
able to bring quicksilver across
and there is potential that toby mcguire
will walk his way through one two
nexus is also the central hub where all
of the information on the internet
travels through
and this was used by the avengers to
track ultron in their second film
wonder is also a nexus being which means
that she's someone who's the same across
all dimensions
every version of wander is wonder and
these people are seen as keystones in
the multiverse
now the word reality that's used here
either means that we got the lagos being
linked to it wrong
or the entire infinity stone theory is
incorrect
i probably should have waited until i'd
watched this episode before setting the
first part of the video after the editor
but we're here now his week's been
ruined and my wife won't talk to me
anymore because of the herpes comment
however the reality stone does appear in
multiple states
and as it's the only stone that can
change its atomic makeup
it does make sense that alternate
versions of it could be in the show
lastly the tagline says because the
world doesn't revolve around you
or it does and this of course links to
wonder the person who the westview world
is built around
captain obvious here with another great
observation there
but i've tricked you into watching until
the end of the video now so
too late to go back on it isn't it
anyway i'd of course
love to hear if there's any ways that
you interpreted the ads differently
so make sure you comment below and let
me know as a thank you for interacting
with the video you'll be entered into a
prize store on the 28th of february
in which we're giving away three copies
of the marvel phase 3 4k box set to our
subscribers
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications on and
drop a comment below with your thoughts
on the commercials
the winners of last month's competition
are on screen right now
so if that's you then message me on
twitter at heavyspoilers you want to
watch something else then make sure you
check out our breakdown of episode 7
which will be linked on screen right now
also thank you for getting me to half a
million subscribers
i don't have to get a proper job now so
so cheers mate
and without the way i mean paul i'll see
you next time yeah
you take care peace